hi everyone my name is Tamra chambers
and this is Tamra just saw and last
night I went and saw twisted-pair
there's only one showing of this in
Chicago at one theater for one night
there's like one showing in every big
city across the states so this is less
of a I think a lot of people are gonna
watch this so I should do an episode of
Tamra to saw of it and more of a I need
to talk about this film with someone I
need to discuss Neil Breen with someone
I'm a little afraid now that I've said
that this is gonna get like six years I
was just filming with a group of
wonderful people a few weeks back and
met Cory Goodwin who introduced me to
Neil Breen and we watched fateful
findings driving back from Springfield
to Chicago and I've been hooked ever
since
Neil green is known as kind of the next
Tommy was so but more so because Tommy
made the room Neil Breen has made five
films now I think there's five of them
twisted-pair being his most recent one
it's just like that perfect mix of
terrible hilarious that you want in a
bad film I also think it's really
endearing he's like this normal guy he's
used to be a real estate agent now he's
an architect in Las Vegas and interviews
with him see he seems just like a really
normal dude and he's he just loves film
so much if people make fun of his films
it's more like I'm just glad people are
watching it versus like he doesn't seem
to be super upset by it and that just
makes you love someone so much or just
for me at least I I'm so so so
fascinated by Neil Breen so Neil if you
see this one I would love to interview
you so so bad - I love your movies I'm
always I said this in the tamara has
never seen episode this week Birdemic ah
with smaller budget things I feel really
shitty shitting on it especially if I
found enjoyment out of it and I was I
had a good time watching it so with this
I
had the best time I think seeing
twisted-pair in the theater was the best
movie going experience I ever had every
time something funny would happen the
crowd went looking but just ballistic it
was so energetic people were screaming I
can barely hear what was going on on the
screen to be quite honest because
everyone was enjoying themselves so much
it's just yelling and responding to
everything I showed up to the theater
thinking like oh you know maybe a
hundred people will be there there was a
line around the block of the music box
and everyone walking up to the line was
like is this for twisted-pair everyone
thought that they were the only ones who
knew who Neal breathe it's the guy
behind me watches nostalgia critic
that's always super fun I had the best
time last night
so to circle back around Neal if you see
this I love your stuff and I do think
that they are they bring me a lot of
enjoyment whether that's because they're
good or not
is something to you know debate but I
love these movies I will also say I've
only seen fateful findings and then
twisted-pair
fateful findings seemed to be pretty
unintentionally bad it felt like this
was just a wonderful mix of a lot of
different aspects that turned into this
flaming pile of awkward badness that was
just super enjoyable to watch this felt
a little more intentional there were a
few things that I was like well I I
think that you maybe do that on purpose
to make it to play into who you now are
is this like cult movie maker okay for
instance there's one scene where there's
this homeless guy sitting on the ground
and there's rats around him but they're
literally these these there's two of
them and in between shots they'll move
them to make it look like they've been
like moving around but their tails it's
like this and like it's literally this
rekt that I have as a Halloween
decoration that I got at the dollar
store so things like that
there's some weird cuts and some weird
lingering shots that
it seems a little intentional now versus
I could be wrong on this but it versus
like fateful findings seems to just be
this organic mess of amazingly bad foam
this felt like oh that did so so well
let's play into it a little bit so I was
just about to explain kind of a brief
synopsis of the movie but guess what I
can't kneel bring wrote directed catered
cast starred and did everything for this
film and he does that in all of his one
of my favorite things is at the end of
fateful findings and this movie in the
credits it'll be like casting in co and
catering in business and all of these
different companies that have ends and
bees in them and then at the very end of
the credits it says anything with the N
or B in it is a fictional company and
was done by Neal Breen I think that's so
funny
Neal Breen plays twins kale and another
character the only difference is one of
them has a really fake beard kale or
cane cane and kale I don't know listen
you guys the names aren't important
there's twins and then somebody takes
them and turns them into powerful
humanoid beings you know for sure and
then they get separated and one of the
first lines in the movie is we were
twins we were inseparable and then it
all changed what you guys being
inseparable or like you guys be doing
what change and then there's a line that
gets repeated throughout the entire
thing and it's I miss what I never knew
it's like but you guys were taken away
after you were inseparable like it seems
like you were maybe 7 or so when you
were taken away so you did know your
brother what are you saying that you
miss being an adult twin miss there's a
CGI Eagle hug and everyone was just
yelling kissed the bird kissed the bird
and it looks like he almost was gonna
kiss the bear so much green screen usage
I said I should say the
the CGI bird it was a green-screen bird
wasn't a CGI bird Tamara come on get
your shit together so then after that
after that short bit of story it gets
really hazy on what is happening the non
bearded twin goes on a mission and
completes the mission and you don't
really know what the mission is and then
he's shown like D gunning he's taking
like all these guns off of his body and
he brought like seven guns to this
mission and he didn't shoot once during
the mission why do you have all these
guns then he runs into this woman and he
makes her drop her papers and it's like
char let me make it up to you I'm gonna
get you a drink and when they let me buy
you a drink
meet me back here at 8:00 maybe back
back here at 8:00 and she's like no god
no and then he follows her home breaks
into her house and then she smashes a
giant painting over his head but there's
no glass there it's just cardboard and
then they add in a bunch of glass
breaking shard noises throughout the
entire scene and they're just like
wrestling on the couch and they're shard
noises happening and then they start
cuddling it was very loud so I don't
really know the vocal interchange that
they had there but it made no goddamn
sense but after that he meets up with
his brother for like the first time in
years and then they're just like alright
well see you later and then they cook
separate ways you have no idea what's
happening the brothers kind of like this
vigilante like Robin Hood type I think
he's like doing good but doing it like
the wrong way and he's got like this
weird torture room that's really all
that I got from this I have no idea what
happened in this movie you guys zero
idea it's kind of like if you've ever
been to a live screening of the room
where they throw the spoons and all that
everyone's so loud that like if you were
to bring someone who had never seen the
room they really wouldn't understand
what was happening at all cuz it's so so
loud so that's really what happened with
this so I can't really speak to the
story but I can it's not good I wrote
two moves in this one shot there's a big
one and then like a weird crop of
another moon for some reason and it's
made to look like it's like a camera
effect maybe you were like something
didn't render correctly but that has to
be in ten
Neal please tell me that it's
intentional there's three cat statues
that keep moving it's unclear why they
keep moving I don't think the woman that
he dates ever had a name in the whole
film I don't think her name was said
once I think my favorite thing about the
movie is the jumps he's got this
superpower he can jump from like qu the
very top of a building and his hair it's
like flapping in the wind oh it is quite
it's quite the movie experience you guys
I would not recommend seeing this alone
I would recommend seeing this with
friends and possibly drinking while
doing it I think that could only
increase the amount of enjoyment that
you get from it probably I want to hear
what everyone thinks of Neal Breen if
you've heard of him if you haven't heard
of him
go watch painful findings it's so great
go watch the trailer to twisted-pair on
youtube it's out of this world it's the
longest trip oh man oh it's a mess and I
loved it
Thank You Neal Breen thanks for watching
I'll see you guys next week bye a movie
prop this is not
[Music]